- [Interviewer] All right, Chelsey.
Chelsey, where'd you grow up,
where are you from originally?
- Virginia.
- What part of Virginia?
- Pocahontas, Virginia.
- [Interviewer] Pocahontas.
Oh, I've been there.
I just came back from there.
- There's less than 500 people.
- [Interviewer] That was incredible.
Yeah, we just drove through there.
I could do a whole
story just on that town.
It's a ghost town now.
- Pretty much.
- So what was the,
it was coal, was your
industry at one time?
- Yes.
- 'Cause there's a downtown,
there's a whole, it's
like an entire small town
with a grocery store, and all
the buildings and everything,
and it's deserted.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] There's not
a single business there.
- The post office and the bank.
- [Interviewer] So the coal
industry left and the town is--
- It's just residents now.
- Yeah, and nobody works.
How long ago did you leave?
- I left,
2012.
- [Interviewer] What was going on in 2012?
- My mom passed away.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- She had cancer.
She passed away at 43.
- I'm sorry.
- (sighs)
- It's hard.
I just lost my mom, too.
So you, tell me about your childhood.
Did you have both your
parents when you were a kid?
- My dad was in and out a lot.
My mom, she was always there.
My mom was my best friend.
- [Interviewer] And you had siblings?
- I had three sisters and a brother.
- [Interviewer] The childhood was good?
- I was raped from the age of eight to 16.
By my dad's dad.
- [Interviewer] Your grandfather.
Did you ever tell anybody?
- Not until I was 16.
I had had my first kid.
He had cholic bad.
And I was up for three days
with him and I thought,
"if somebody'd done this
to him, I'd kill 'em."
And I finally said something.
- [Interviewer] So, who is
the father of your child?
- Not my grandfather.
- Not your grandfather.
- No.
- [Interviewer] And you,
did anything happen to your
grandfather after that?
- He did four years in prison.
It's like, that's nowhere
near what he done to me.
It just seems unfair.
But...
- [Interviewer] So you,
where'd your life go
after that all happened?
You had a child, how many
children do you have now?
- I have three.
Three boys.
When my mom died,
I was going through a
custody battle with my kids.
And,
my youngest two's dad was getting high.
I was always around it,
but I wouldn't do it.
But the day my mom died, I did.
I quit going to court for my kids.
My whole life was to make my mom happy.
When she died, I didn't care anymore.
So I left home, I went to Denver
for a year, and then I went back home
for like, two or three.
Seen my sister.
And then this last time I
left, I went back to Denver.
And I've been in California
going on three years now.
- So you went to Colorado
and you left your children behind?
- My sister,
my sister's mother-in-law
got custody of 'em.
- [Interviewer] And drugs were
in your life at that point
for the whole period?
- Yeah.
- What's your drug?
- Then, it was crack.
And then, I switched
to crystal.
But I haven't, the crack
was my, my drug of choice.
Like, it took everything.
- [Interviewer] You stay
in touch with your kids?
- As much as my sister will let me.
- [Interviewer] And then, how
were you supporting yourself
when you were in Colorado?
- I had a job for a little bit at a hotel.
And prostitution.
I haven't, my kids' dad, he would
do his little thing to make money,
but when me and him split up, I just
had a couple pimps I worked for.
And then when I got here, I met
this guy named Trey.
He actually kept me from killing myself.
- [Interviewer] Are you depressed a lot?
(sniffling)
(sobbing)
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] What's
the hardest part for you,
being separated from your kids?
- That, and my mom.
- And your mom, yeah.
(sighing)
- I'm the oldest out
of all of my siblings.
And all my other siblings took it hard,
but not as hard as I did.
My youngest sister
started going to church.
And I completely went in
the opposite direction.
(sniffling)
- [Interviewer] The sexual abuse you had
when you were young, was that something
your sisters went through, too?
- One of my sisters, the one that's
two years younger than me.
But she told the same day it happened.
And,
he,
he got put on probation or,
it was like, nothing.
And,
the way my family treated her,
I was like, I can't say anything.
- [Interviewer] How did they treat her?
- My dad,
he was like, "you're a liar.
"You're just doing it for money."
We didn't get any money
to tell what really happened.
They said some really
hurtful things about her.
- [Interviewer] So that made it difficult
for you to come out.
- And when I finally did,
that's the first person I told, was her.
'Cause it was, I was like, "I'm sorry
"that I didn't stick up for you."
(sniffling) And now, we don't even talk.
(sniffling)
- [Interviewer] The drug use helps you
deal with it all, right?
- Not necessarily deal with it, but
not think about it as much.
- Not deal with it, yeah.
- 'Cause whenever you
come down, it's like,
it's 10 times more than
what it would've been
if you would've just dealt with it.
- [Interviewer] So then,
you came to LA at one point.
How long you been here?
- Going on three years.
- [Interviewer] And you've
been staying on Skid Row?
Do you have a tent?
- No.
(sniffling) I finally got
an SRO.
- Oh, that's nice.
But you were on the street for a while?
- Yeah.
I was in between
like,
with this guy I had
met and on the streets.
It's hard for me on the streets.
People think I'm just,
a pushover, I guess.
And they try to take advantage of me.
I've been robbed.
(sighing)
(sniffling)
I don't think I would be able to get by
if it really wasn't for
the animals that I've got.
They keep me busy.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
any friends in your life now?
- A couple, but not someone
that I talk to regularly.
Just like, if I see 'em
pass by or whatever,
I'll talk to 'em.
- [Interviewer] But not real friends.
Do you have anyone that you trust?
(sniffling)
- No.
- Are you here mainly just
'cause that's where the
drugs are easy to find?
- No.
My favorite place is the beach.
And like,
I like the point that it's
just a 45-minute train ride,
and I'm there.
That's my,
when I go to the beach, it's
like nothing else matters.
But it took me
a minute
to get back to even anywhere
close to where I used to be.
It just feels good to have my own spot.
- [Interviewer] So your
kids and your family
are still back in Pocahontas?
And going back there is not a,
I mean, the kids are there,
but nothing else is there, right?
- The nursing home my mom was in
was at the end of my street.
(sniffling)
- [Interviewer] Where
would you like to see
your life go from here?
(sniffling)
- I just started school again.
And I'm hoping to start
on some college classes.
(sniffling)
I eventually want my
kids to come out here.
(sighing)
- [Interviewer] Have
you been clean before?
You have.
- I got clean for,
like, two years.
- [Interviewer] Was it difficult?
- It was easier than
I thought it would be,
but
I quit.
No rehab, nothing.
But one day, I was like,
it was Mother's Day.
And I was like,
and I gave it all up again.
(sniffling)
It's been eight years since I lost my mom,
and I still haven't grieved over her.
My ex would tell me, "it's
done, it's over with.
"Get over it."
How do you get over it?
(sniffling)
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you lost a lot.
You lost your mom, you lost your kids,
your town is even gone.
- Yeah. (sniffling)
I've lost my stepmom
since I've been out here.
(sniffling)
- [Interviewer] But you're
still hopeful, a little bit.
Right?
That's great.
- I try to be. (sniffling)
- [Interviewer] I mean,
just taking classes,
is a big deal.
- It's a lot of work.
It's like I can't remember
anything I learned
when I was in school.
- [Interviewer] What would
you like to do with your life?
- [Chelsey] I don't know if
I wanna work with animals
or something where I'm
pretty much by myself.
Like, some type of office job where,
I don't even know,
completely.
- [Interviewer] Do you
talk with your sisters?
- [Chelsey] One of 'em.
The baby.
She's 20.
But I feel like our relationship
is slowly drifting away.
(sniffling)
(sobbing)
(sighing)
(sniffling)
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- 29. (sniffling)
(sobbing)
(sighing)
(sniffling)
- [Interviewer] Can you
imagine going back to Virginia,
to Pocahontas, or would you
bring your kids out here?
- I would wanna bring 'em out here.
There's nothing there anymore.
- Yeah.
- But I know the first thing
I gotta do is get clean.
- [Interviewer] Yep.
- 'Cause there's no way
I want my kids to see me.
(sniffling)
- [Interviewer] What do you
think would help you get clean?
Have you tried rehabs?
No?
- No.
I've said I was gonna
do it a couple of times,
but I always had an excuse why I didn't.
(sniffling)
(sighing)
I think it might be time.
(sniffling)
(gentle music)